foreign
in the summer of 1764 the once wealthy
and peaceful French province of jevadar
fell victim to a series of brutal and
wild attacks the populace were overcome
with fear having no explanation as to
what was happening the public hysteria
spiraled out of control and created a
monster over the next two years the
Beast of javadar would ravage the land
and its people until the attack suddenly
stopped but what exactly was this
creature some say it was a hyena others
a wolf there have been theories
suggesting a possible hybrid creature
maybe even a lion those who remain
skeptical believe it was and must have
been a wolfdog of sorts on the other end
of the spectrum we see claims that the
Beast of javadar is proof of the
existence of werewolves so join me today
as we dive into this mystery and try to
decipher what may have been facts and
what may have been fiction
today's video has been made possible by
bespoke post bespoke post is a monthly
membership club that delivers a box of
awesome top shelf goods from a variety
of under the radar Brands it's free to
join and you can skip any given month or
cancel at any time ninety percent of the
products come from small Brands many of
which are based inside the US every
month members receive a variety of new
products that range from outdoor gear
barware home and kitchen goods clothing
and much more based on the preference
quiz taken by members bespoke posts will
then be able to gauge what kind of box
you should be sent every box of awesome
has around 70 dollars worth of goods
inside but only costs a fraction of the
price before your box is shipped you're
given the chance to preview what's
inside from there you have several
choices you can keep the box you can
swap the box for another or you can
decide to skip the month in time
entirely at no charge you only ever pay
for things that you want the Weekender
box for example comes with an heirloom
level carryall a high quality carry bag
that's perfect for any weekend trips
being able to fit clothing accessories
books and laptops with no issue the
energize box includes two 16 ounce cold
brew concentrates one regular caffeine
and one extra caffeine you also get two
two ounce cold brew concentrates one low
caffeine and one extra caffeine to get
twenty percent off your first box of
awesome you can click on the link in the
description and use the code
mfe20 at checkout or you can visit
bespopepost.com
mfe20 to get your discount today
foreign
the first sighting of the Beast came in
the summer of 1764 in the Makwa Forest
where a young woman was tending her
cattle Marie JaVale saw something that
she could only describe as like a wolf
but not a wolf the Beast began to charge
towards her but the Bulls and her cattle
were able to keep the Beast away it made
a second attempt but this attack was
also repelled the animal retreated into
the woods before Marie could make out
what exactly her attacker was the Beast
continued to ravage the countryside
throughout the year and the first
recorded fatal attack was of a 14 year
old girl out in the fields with her
cattle the body of Jean bullet was found
mutilated in a small village in between
Montpellier and Saint Etienne as the
attacks became more common women and
children were warned not to travel alone
especially when tending cattle in the
fields as this is when the Beast was
most likely to strike however the Beast
of javadan did not discriminate as it
would also attack men who traveled by
themselves by the end of the year the
sheer amount of attacks as well as the
fact that some attacks appeared to
happen simultaneously LED people to
believe that these must have been
committed by more than one animal some
eyewitness accounts reported seeing the
Beast accompanied by another animal
other accounts state that the second
animal was of a similar appearance but
much smaller in size leading to the
theory that the Beast of javadan
traveled with its child what made the
Beast of jevadon difficult to identify
were the manner of the attacks a human
killed by an animal who is hunting for
food makes sense what makes less sense
is how this beast in particular was more
interested in tearing its victims apart
it would always start by attacking the
neck and the head but instead of feeding
on the carcass it would Shred the body
to Pieces severed limbs would commonly
be found scattered around the area these
attacks took place this led to the
belief that the Beast did not hunt out
of necessity but instead pleasure as
news spread it was clear the people of
jevadan needed assistance with their
monster problem the events that took
place on the 12th of January 1765 would
be the Catalyst for Royal and state
intervention a young boy Jacques
poteffer was tending cattle out in the
fields with a group of children it
wasn't common for the Beast to attack a
group of people but as they were quite
young perhaps it did not expect much of
a struggle Jacques and his companions
however were able to fend off the
Beastie using Pikes news of this attack
spread fast and managed to reach the
then King of France King Louis XV King
Louis gave the boy in his companions a
monetary reward for their bravery and
even provided Jack with an education
that would be paid for by the state the
king then declared that jevadan would no
longer have to suffer in silence the
French state would do everything in its
power to kill the Beast King Louie's
first course of action was to send first
captain duomill of the clemon prince
dragons the captain and his Gods arrived
in javadar however they struggled to
coordinate their efforts of the local
villagers and Farmers dumel's time in
javadar was a resounding failure he
crossed paths with a beast several times
but failed to land any of the shots he
fired doomel's frustration reached an
all-time high when his plan to intercept
the Beast crossing a river fell apart
due to the local Village not being
present or even willing to cooperate the
first Captain even threw his own men
under the bus citing the incompetence of
his guards as another reason his
attempts were unsuccessful needless to
say King Louis needed another plan this
time he sent two seasoned Hunters who
were experts in tracking and hunting
wolves the arrival of Jean charlier Mark
Antoine and his son Jean Francois meant
it was time for Captain Duo Mill to step
down and return to his headquarters in
Claremore Captain Duo Mill favored the
strategy of organizing hunting parties
whereas Jean charlay and his son
disagreed believing the only way to
shoot the Beast would be by employing a
much more stealthy approach they also
believe that the beast in question would
be found amongst Eurasian wolves and
that's where they chose to focus their
search using Bloodhounds to Aid them
however as the attacks continued the
Father and Son were replaced meaning
their time in charge of hunting the
Beast lasted from February until June
they were replaced by the king's
lieutenant of the hunt Francois Antoine
on September 21st Antoine killed a large
gray wolf the size of the wolf was
unlike anything he had seen before which
led to a public statement claiming they
had killed what they believed to have
been the Beast of javadar in order for
them to verify this they needed the
survivors of its attacks to help them
cross-reference the victims were able to
confirm this Theory by identifying the
scars on the Beast which they were
responsible for when defending
themselves once the body was identified
it would be sent to King Louie's Palace
where Antoine's son would receive the
accolades for his father who remained in
jevadan to hunt the partner of the Beast
and her two children after killing both
children Francois returned to King Louis
where he received a rather handsome
monetary reward in early December of the
same year two young boys were attacked
but the eldest was able
a dozen attacks followed which led many
to believe that the Beast of jevadong
may not actually be dead the Resurgence
of the attacks could no longer be
ignored and so a nobleman in jevadan
took things into his own hands
organizing a Hunting Party June 19
1767 is when the attacks were said to
have finally ceased local Hunter Jean
shastel was credited with killing the
Beast during a Hunting Party when
examining this large wolf there were
human remains found in its stomach
considering there were no more reported
attacks these two factors were enough
for the people of javadan to finally
believe the Beast had been slain given
the frequency of the attacks we
discussed earlier it's likely that both
wolf slain were responsible for the
attacks hence why they slowed down after
the first was slain and completely
stopped when the second was slain over
the two to three year span the Beast of
javadar was responsible for hundreds of
attacks and fatal injuries the exact
number however is a bit more difficult
to gauge some predict around 100
children and adults were attacked a
study from 1987 estimates that they were
210 attacks which resulted in 113 deaths
and 49 injuries 98 of the victims killed
were partially eaten none of the victims
who survived died from rabies which
ruled out the possibility of rabid
wolves being responsible for the attacks
attacks from wolves in not only France
but Europe as a whole was a big problem
in the 18th century and so rationalizing
the Beast of jevadar as the work of not
just one wolf but perhaps a pack or even
more is the most simple solution other
theories include a runaway lion or hyena
that had escaped from a Zoo the Father
and Son Hunter Duo describe the Beast as
being much larger than a wolf having a
snout like a calf and very long hair to
some this supports the idea that a hyena
could have escaped her zoo and found
itself in javadar first Captain duomil
described the Beast as having a body as
long as a leopard and a breast as wide
as a horse it had fur that was red with
a black stripe he claimed that if you
saw the Beast you would assume it was
some kind of hybrid monster some
witnesses describe fiery red eyes and
the ability to repel bullets with ease
it could even stand on its hind legs and
thus we have the theory that it could
have been a werewolf another theory is
that there was a serial killer in
javadar who used the Beast as a cover-up
for all of the murders committed a once
peaceful and idyllic Village in southern
France all of a sudden becoming home to
a monster responsible for hundreds of
attacks certainly sounds like some kind
of a movie or fictional story except it
happened nearly 260 years ago and yet we
still don't have a definitive answer to
the most important question what was the
Beast of javadar
[Music]
foreign